a blue themed expansive visual space
with text open science open science is
really an umbrella term that includes a
lot of different practices we
see that enable people to access the
results of science Miriam's arumglam PhD
data science and open science officer
when I first learned about open science
subscribe to me really resting on three
pillars you have open data meaning that
the data are made openly available that
they're shared you have open source
which means that the underlying
analytical tools and software and code
are made openly available and then you
have open access which is that
Publications that are sort of the
synthesis of the data and the results
that came after the analysis are also
made openly available for folks to read
a man is speaking in front of a
classroom nlm is really interested in
creating expertise and knowledge about
data not just in you know the research
institution or in libraries but also
preparing the public to be more data
Savvy overhead view of four people
talking and working around a table
having as many people as possible who
are able to access the data who are able
to look under the hood make science more
rigorous because you have more folks who
are able to sort of tap into this data
tap into your code have access to the
Publications that result from it and
engage in this consensus building that
is so incredibly important and
foundational for science to move forward
we're in a position that we can talk
with Publishers about why Open Access is
important or talk with them about why
they should be instituting data citation
which would make it easier for us to
track data composite of the nlm logo
with text the National Library of
Medicine accelerating biomedical
Discovery and data powered Health we
have a really unique
forward some of the practices that will
lead to more open science Montage of
medical imagery leads to a dark-themed
world map with twinkling points of light
over major cities NIH nlm gray and blue
logo with underlying great text serving
scientists and Society